berti ragazzi benvenuti 0 i dolori sono
parigi oggi siamo tornati su uno dei
giochi più qui ricomincia la scuola non
solo sul lei di che era quel gioco e non
so se ve lo ricordate che c'è la zia che
ci segue ok io non ero riuscito a
finirlo perché era non uscivo trovate
tutte le pagine quelle dei compiti
perché tu cosa fai tu vai nella scuola a
cercare i test per l'esame per derubarli
è una volta che li ritrovi li metti
tutti insieme e paesei promosso è però
c'è la zia e la zia che adesso vi faccio
vedere la zia st solito non c'è meno
male o poi arriva tutto troviamo dieci
pagine degli esami che non solo nello
stesso posto ogni volta che rispondi
quindi vediamo di non morire un casino
flash a led gau pavia io ho trovato la
pagina finale delle risposte bene dello
stesso modo in cui ho passato l'esame da
patente però fa niente non ho idea era
molto difficile la voce al canto ragazzi
un mesetto fa non solo li porterà molto
difficile suo gioco perché poi la zia
quando inizia a correre
devi schivarla perché tira le pentole è
un grammy molto più difficile
sostanzialmente eccola la zia ha aperto
tutto non ha visto non ha visto non ha
visto non l'ha visto non mai visto non
ha visto non ha visto non ha visto non
ha visto roma disco mi sarei mai visto e
stravisto scritto mi ha visto
hai aperto le beta ma la perda nei
tunnel aperta la porta che sapeva bene
lo fa niente col
migliore è 2 vado non c'è niente tutto
chiuso e due cover come sfuggo che ho
trovato un kit no perché ce l'ho già in
mano un altra chiave perfetta ho trovato
una chiave e basta cioè due ore sono
stato a girare neanche un testo trovato
solo la chiave
mandaci una ancora quotidiani sto
trovando ecco test 3d 10
madonna ragazza è veramente se sono run
tonici ci sto avendo una sfiga
incredibile perché non ho trovato mezzo
girato 62 posti
ho trovato mezzo test devo stare attento
perché se
hai rubato vi dai un'altra paginetta ti
prego
ok la zia quadrati e quella senza un
buon dio
oddio mi aspettavo così facile forte vai
turni c'è la portano controllata non fa
niente di report e ciao e va beh sì ma è
prima o poi prima o poi la semi nero nel
senso di un posto sacro a due anni
ok spero che sia riuscito a segnalarla
non ne sono sicurissimo non è solo su
cui sono nel bagno nel bagno del bagno
in bagno e bagno semi via cosa morto
somma cosa facciamo ci sono auto moto
sono dentro non solo dentro e il
trecento vabbè non mi ha visto non ha
visto come fate a posto possibile che in
200 stanze abbia trovato un test per gli
esami e basta uno solo però c'è una
sedia sul su una scrivania ben servito a
quello
io benedetto non me l'aspettavo mai
castris per
miglior prospetto e va beh son orto non
ho idea di come sfuggire a questa cosa
nelle docce
oddio lo schivato odio aiuto
[Applauso]
dai madonna impossibile però forse non
mi ha ucciso sai non mi ha ucciso una
pedana della tana da questa è veramente
una visione orribile ma brutta proprio
se posso essere sincero using markit ben
fortunatamente non sono morto però ho
visto cose che voi umani non potete
neanche immaginare
in tutto questo neanche una pagina
dell'esame quando ho fatto il 62
schivate watchmen quell'uomo
sfruttate ascoltiamo in questo momento
in cui pensa che io sia morto per
trovare pagine che non ci sono comunque
le stanno davanti a noi non esistono per
quanto è grosso suo posto non trovo un
test per gli esami manco a pagarlo
è la vera che spiegato
io gli farei una detartrasi se però
qualcuno entrata nel gioco qualcuno è
entrato nel gioco ragazzo sono qui da
solo
è entrato qualcuno possono morire
ma dai ma che caso la possibile però
quadro a venire ma che cacchio faccia
del suo scrivere
perché gli amici di lana roba
è c'è uno zio che gioca con me non solo
e sia però un altro potrà dunque l'esame
quattro anni dieci
sono andata non sono andato per niente
bene i due players bellissimo two player
su juan scuola abbandonata fantastico
poche qual è la caffetteria spero che
sia andata agli altri player anche se io
non li ho ancora visti almeno per certo
ci distribuiamo un po di difficoltà no
perché la sento che urla
salve
tutto ciò è bellissimo se io vado
uno è stato colpito e ucciso
proprio aiuto
stanno in palestra loro mangiamo poteva
andare altra ma proprio in palestra
deleterio lo zio sicuro io posso curarti
oldman ti posso non posso mi spiego sono
incastrato ci sono incastrato nella rete
ma nasce in palestra ci sono esami
wrobel avete presi non lo so mi metto
gli importa tu tiri che facciamo in
palestra c'è gente ma cosa stai seguendo
vero ha detto sei dietro bene lo zio
seguite io non posso curarlo questo
perché non me lo fa curare
anzi lo fa volare ok tienilo tienilo di
riordino tiro di nocerino
let's go pro recco rigore ma aveva
ragazzi che destrezza c'avete ceva cos'è
ragazzi che l'aveva vista se quel porco
del demonio morto proprio media eseguire
credo che cambi il target ragazzi andate
dall'altra parte che apro la porta
almeno soffrendo è apro qua
apro qua bene non ho idea neanche di che
cosa ci sia però almeno spostiamoci
perché non siamo sempre là ragazzi ma
anche al 4 pagine signori quattro pagine
in tre spero vivamente riuscire a jeda
non è finita che cazzo a ciò è vero che
c'è la messa faceva 01 è stato buttato
giù dal lancio lady perfetto io ho
trovato la pagina
ne mancano tre io sto melkita non lo uso
per nessuno vi in groppa 12 pagine
c'erano immensa fantastico manca mancano
mancano due ne manca una sarà
nell'ufficio del direttore ma bisogna
avere del preside ma bisogna avere
almeno almeno la chiave perché era
chiusa e non solo sia la chiave del
preside sinceramente che ci a te cosa
state scrivendo tra tutte le basi per lo
zio quando non ti devi svegliare ti
prego non posso usare buttare tutti i
miei medikit perché tu finisci per terra
c'è santo iddio almeno muoviti non ho
idea di dove sia la chiave per il del
preside non lo so però manca 22 esami è
quella dove trovare gas
ragazzi se la zia mi colpisce io sono
per terra non ho più mcitaly usati tutti
per voi vi ho curati come se foste i
miei figli e non lo siete aiuto
toglietevi di colpa perché se questo non
è poi tanto e sono quello forte del
gioco cioè non ho capito mi sembra un po
eccessivo
mettera la parola ayala preso
snoop doubt sono vivo però ancora posso
trascinarmi mi potete restare li prego
mi sono alzato a noi la torcia che è
successo io penso
siamo degli stronzi
niente ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
questo c'erano questo mi piace anche
all'isolamento deliziare i soliti
rischia teheran come sempre ci diamo a
lui prossimo nido della ragazza
[Musica]